you
this week we commemorate the
extraordinary courage and sacrifice of
those who gave their lives for our
Liberty on d-day
seventy-five years ago as leaders
prepare to gather here from across the
world it is fitting that we begin with
the celebration of the special
relationship between the United Kingdom
and the United States enduring partners
who stood side-by-side on that historic
day and every day since four generations
at the heart of the transatlantic
alliance has been our shared democratic
values our common interests and our
commitment to justice it is that unity
of purpose that will preserve the
deep-rooted ties between our people and
underpin our nation's security and
prosperity for the next 75 years and
beyond so I am very pleased to welcome
the President of the United States of
America on this state visit to the
United Kingdom for the past
two-and-a-half years the president and I
have had the duty and privilege of being
the latest guardians of this precious
and profound friendship between our
countries as with our predecessors when
we have faced threats to the security of
our citizens and our allies we have
stood together and acted together when
Russia used a deadly nerve agent on the
streets of our country alongside the
UK's expulsion the president expelled 60
Russian intelligence officers the
largest contribution towards an
unprecedented global response and in
Syria when innocent men women and
children were victims of a barbaric
chemical weapons attack Britain and
America along with France carried out
targeted strikes against the regime
since we spoke about NATO during my
first visit to the White House we have
maintained our support for this crucial
alliance thanks in part your clear
message on burden-sharing Donald we have
seen members pledged another one
hundred billion dollars increasing their
contributions to our shared security and
I'm pleased to announce that NATO will
soon be able to call on the UK's queen
elizabeth-class aircraft carriers and
f-35 fighter jets to help tackle threats
around the world today we've discussed
again the new and evolving challenges to
our security our values and our way of
life we share the same view about their
origin and our objectives in meeting
them but like prime ministers and
presidents before us and no doubt those
that will come after we can also differ
sometimes on how to confront the
challenges we face I've always talked
openly with you Donald when we have
taken a different approach and you've
done the same with me I've always
believed that cooperation and compromise
are the basis of strong alliances and
nowhere is this more true than in the
special relationship today we've
discussed again the importance of our
two nations working together to address
Iran's destabilizing activity in the
region and to ensure Iran cannot acquire
a nuclear weapon although we differ on
the means of achieving that as I've said
before the UK continues to stand by the
nuclear deal it is clear that we both
want to reach the same goal it is
important that Iran meets its
obligations and we do everything to
avoid escalation which is in no one's
interest recognizing our nations are
safer and more prosperous when we work
together on the biggest challenges of
our time I also set out the UK's
approach to tackling climate change and
our continued support for the Paris
agreement and we also spoke about China
recognizing its economic significance
and that we cannot ignore action that
threatens our shared interests or values
as we've deepened our cooperation on
security including our joint military
operations and our unparalleled
intelligence sharing so our economies to
our ever more tightly bound together
every morning 1 million Americans get up
and go to work for British companies in
America and 1 million Britons do the
same for American companies here our
trading relationship is worth over 190
billion pounds a year and we're the
largest investors in each other's
economies with mutual investments valued
at as
as one trillion dollars mr. president
you and I agreed the first time we met
that we should aim for an ambitious free
trade agreement when the UK leaves the
EU and from our positive discussions
today I know that we both remain
committed to this I'm also sure that our
economic relationship will only grow
broader and deeper building on the
conversations we had and the ideas we
heard from UK and US businesses when we
met them earlier today tomorrow we will
sit down in Portsmouth with our fellow
leaders to Rio for but reaffirm the
enduring importance of the Western
alliance and the shared values that
underpin it and as we look to the future
in the years and in the generations
ahead we will continue to work together
to preserve the alliance that is the
bedrock of our shared prosperity and
security just as it was on the beaches
of Normandy 75 years ago mr. president
well Thank You Prime Minister may Lonnie
and I are honored to return to London as
our nation's commemorate the 75th
anniversary of d-day in World War two we
want to thank her Majesty the Queen who
I had a lovely dinner with the last
night a fantastic person fantastic woman
for so graciously inviting us to this
state visit it was very very special our
thanks as well to Prime Minister and mr.
May for the warm welcome
they've given the first lady and me as
we remember the heroes who laid down
their lives to rescue civilization
itself on June 6th 1944 tens of
thousands of young warriors left the
shores by the sea and air to begin the
invasion of Normandy and the liberation
of Europe and the brutal Nazi occupation
it was a liberation like few people have
seen before
among them were more than 130,000
American and British brothers in arms
through their valor and sacrifice they
secured our homelands and save freedom
for the world tomorrow Prime Minister
may and I will attend a commemoration
ceremony in Portsmouth one of the key
embarked Asian points for the invasion
more than one and a half million
American servicemembers was stationed
right here in England in advance of the
landings that summer the bonds of
friendship forged here and sealed in
blood on those hallowed beaches will
endure forever our special relationship
is grounded in common history values
customs culture language and laws our
people believe in freedom and
independence as a sacred birthright and
cherished inheritance worth defending at
any cost
as the Prime Minister and I discussed in
our meetings today and yesterday the
United States and the United Kingdom
share many goals and priorities around
the world
I want to thank the people of the United
Kingdom for their service and
partnership in our campaign to defeat
Isis as we announced a few months ago
Isis's territorial Caliphate in Syria in
Iraq has been completely obliterated
defeated the United Kingdom is also a
key partner in NATO the Prime Minister
and I agree that our NATO allies must
increase their defence spending we've
both been working very hard toward that
end and we are very current and some of
them are not we can't allow that to
happen but I appreciate everything
you've done in that regard we expect a
growing number of nations to meet the
minimum 2 percent of GDP requirement to
address today's challenges all members
of the Alliance must fulfill their
obligations they have no choice they
must fulfill their obligation among the
pressing threats facing our nations is
the development and spread of nuclear
weapons
perhaps that's our greatest threat the
United States and the United Kingdom are
determined to ensure that Iran never
develops nuclear weapons and stop
supporting and engaging in terrorism and
I believe that will happen in protecting
our nation's we also know that the
border security is national security
today the Prime Minister and I discussed
our thriving economic relationship both
countries are doing very well and
participated in a roundtable with
industry and business leaders I can say
probably the biggest business leaders
anywhere in the world our nations have
more than 1 trillion dollars invested in
each other's economics the United
Kingdom is America's largest foreign
investor in our largest European export
market that's a lot of importance as the
UK makes preparations to exit the
European Union the United States is
committed to a phenomenal trade deal
between the u.s. and the UK there is
tremendous potential in that trade
I say probably two and even three times
of what we're doing right now tremendous
potential 75 years ago this Thursday
courageous Americans and British
Patriots set out from this island toward
history's most important battle they
stormed forward out of ships and
airplanes risking everything to defend
our people and to ensure that the United
States and Britain would forever remain
sovereign and forever remain free
following this press conference Prime
Minister may mr. May the first lady my
family and I will visit the legendary
Churchill war rooms beneath the streets
of London I look forward to that in his
famous speech on this day in June 1940
Prime Minister Churchill urge his
countrymen to defend our island whatever
the cost may be as we mark this solemn
anniversary of d-day we remember that
the defense of our nations does not
begin on the battlefield but within the
heart of every Patriot today let us
renew our pledge engraved at the
American Cemetery in Normandy and
inscribed by President Dwight Eisenhower
in st. Paul's Cathedral right here in
London that the cause for which they
died shall live Prime Minister may it's
been a true honor I have greatly enjoyed
working with you you are a tremendous
professional and a person that loves
your country dearly thank you very much
really an honor thank you for the
invitation to memorialize our fallen
heroes and for your partnership in
protecting and advancing the
extraordinary alliance between the
American and the British people it's the
greatest alliance the world has ever
known
Thank You Prime Minister thank you thank
you
thank you now we're going to take two
questions from the UK media and two
questions from the American media I'll
start with Beth Rigby thank you Thank
You Prime Minister president Trump Beth
Rigby from Sky News for You president
Trump has you hold talks with the
current Prime Minister the leader of Her
Majesty's opposition has been addressed
in a protest rally against your visit in
Trafalgar Square
he says he's disappointed you attacked
the London mayor and he criticized your
record on refugees what do you have to
say to him and is this man someone you
could do a trade deal with and to you
prime minister do you think that Sadiq
Khan is a stone-cold loser thank you
you're talking about the Mayor of London
is that who you said yes well I think
he's been a not very good mayor from
what I understand he's done a poor job
crime is up a lot of problems and I
don't think he should be criticizing a
representative of the United States that
can do so much good for the United
Kingdom we talked about it before he
should be positive not negative he's a
negative force not a positive force and
if you look at what he said he hurts the
people of this great country and I think
he should actually focus on his job it'd
be a lot better if he did that he could
straighten out some of the problems that
he has and probably some of the problems
that he's caused thank you good night
yes you wanted to meet with me and I
told him no yes well I don't know Jeremy
Corbyn never met him never spoke to him
he wanted to meet today or tomorrow and
I I decided that I would not do that I
think that he is from where I come from
somewhat of a negative force I think
that people should look to do things
correctly as opposed to criticize I
really don't like critics as much as I
like and respect people as far as the
process I have to and even coming over
today there were thousands of people
cheering accommodate and then I heard
that there were protests I said where
are the protests I don't see any protest
I did see a small protest today when I
came very small so a lot of it is fake
news I hate to say it but you saw the
people waving the American flag waving
your flag it was tremendous spirit and
love there was great love there was an
alliance and I didn't see the protesters
or just a little while ago and it was a
very very small group of people put in
for political reasons so it was fake
news and Jeremy Corbyn the discussions
that we have had today
that was great love there was an
alliance
I didn't a little while ago and it was a
very very small group of people put in
for political reasons so it was fake
news thank you and I would say to both
the Mayor of London and to Jeremy Corbyn
the discussions that we have had today
are about the future of this most
important relationship between the u.s.
and the UK as the president described it
the greatest alliance the world has seen
it is this deep special relationship and
partnership between the United States
and the United Kingdom that ensures our
safety and security and the safety and
security of others around the world -
and it is this relationship that helps
to ensure there are jobs that employ
people here in the UK and in the United
States that underpins our prosperity and
our future that is a relationship we
should cherish it is a relationship we
should build on it is a relationship we
should be proud of this big and this
really is a very big and important
alliance and I think people should act
positively toward it because it means so
much for both countries means so much
and it's been so good Steve Holland yes
Thank You mr. prank is that fun there
what is your current view on brexit sir
she had britain leave the european union
if there is no agreement by october 31st
and for the prime minister what would be
the ramifications for the UK if there is
not a deal well I don't like to take
positions and things that I'm not you
know really I understand the issue very
well I really predicted what was going
to happen some of you remember that
prediction it was a strong prediction
made at a certain location on a
development we were opening the day
before it happened and I thought it was
going to happen because of immigration
more than anything else but probably it
happens for a lot of reasons but I would
say yeah I would think that it will
happen and it probably should happen
this is a great great country and it
wants its own identity it wants to have
its own borders it wants to run its own
affairs this is a very very special
place and I think it deserves a special
place and I thought maybe for that
reason and for others but that reason it
was going to happen yeah I think it will
happen and I believe the Prime
Minister's brought it to a very good
point where something will take place in
the not-too-distant future I think she's
done a very good job I believe it would
be good for the country yes and from my
point of view I believe it is important
for us to deliver brexit we gave that
choice to the British people Parliament
overwhelmingly gave the choice to the
British people we should now deliver on
that choice I continue to believe that
actually it's in the best interest of
the UK to leave the European Union in an
orderly way with a deal I think we have
a good deal sadly the Labour Party and
other MPs have so far doctors from
delivering brexit in that deal but we
will but obviously this is an issue that
is going to continue here in the UK I
think the important thing is we deliver
brexit and once we're out of the
European Union we will be able to do
what we've been talking about today and
develop not just that free trade
agreement that a broader economic
partnership into the future
matter mr. president are you prepared to
impose limits on intelligence sharing
with Britain if they do not put in place
some restrictions on Huawei no because
we're gonna have absolutely an agreement
on Huawei and everything else we have an
incredible intelligence relationship and
we will be able to work out any
differences I think we're not gonna have
we did discuss it I see absolutely no
limitations we've never had limitations
this is a truly great ally and partner
and we'll have no problem with that okay
Francis
mr. president France télécom times do
you agree with your ambassador that's
the entire economy needs to be on the
table in a future trade talk a trade
deal including the MHS and Prime
Minister EU tempted to take the Prime
Minister president of the world and
stick around for a bit until a trade
deal is done I think we're going to have
a great trade deal yes I think we're
going to have a great and very
comprehensive trade deal look I think
everything with the trade deal is on the
table when you when you're dealing and
trade everything's on the table so NHS
or anything else you're a lot a lot more
than that but everything will be on the
table absolutely okay but the point
about making trade deals is of course
that both sides negotiate and come to an
agreement about what should or should
not be in that trade deal for the for
the future and as regards your second
question
Frances nice try but but no look I'm a
woman of my word
John mr. president thank you mr.
president
domestically in recent days Mexico has
stepped up apprehensions and
deportations of Central American
migrants it's good this could possibly
be in response to your threat of tariffs
as Mexico possibly be has it has Mexico
done enough to avoid tariffs which will
be imposed in some six days from now and
and but the threat is out there this
will take effect next week and what some
percent and what do you think of
Republicans who say that they may take
action to block you imposing those two I
don't think they will do that I think if
they do it's foolish there's nothing
more important than borders I've had
tremendous Republican support I have a
ninety percent ninety four percent
approval rating as of this morning in
the Republican Party that's an all-time
record can you believe that isn't that
something I love records but we have a
94 percent approval rating in the
Republican Party
I want to see security at our border I'm
gonna see great trade I'm gonna see a
lot of things happening and that is
happening and as you know Mexico call
they want to meet they're gonna meet on
Wednesday secretary Pompeo is going to
be at the meeting along with a few
others that are very good at this and we
are going to see if we can do something
but I think it's more likely that the
tariffs go on and we'll probably be
talking during the time that the tariffs
are on and they're going to be paid and
if they don't step up and give us
security for our nation look millions of
people are flowing through Mexico that's
unacceptable millions and millions of
people are coming right through Mexico
it's a 2,000 mile journey and they're
coming up to our border and our Border
Patrol which is incredible they're
apprehending them but our laws are bad
because the Democrats don't want to pass
laws that could be passed in 15 minutes
that could be passed quickly in one day
it could change but even beyond the laws
Mexico shouldn't allow millions of
people to try and enter our country and
they could stop it
very quickly and I think they will and
if they won't we're gonna put tariffs on
and every month those tariffs go from 5
percent to 10 percent to 15 percent to
20 and then to 25 percent and what will
happen then is all of those companies
that have left our country and gone to
Mexico are going to be coming back to us
and that's okay that's okay but I think
Mexico will step up and do what they
should have been done and I don't want
to hear that Mexico is run by the
cartels and the drug lords and the
Coyotes I don't want to hear about that
a lot of people are saying that Mexico
has something to prove but I don't want
to hear that they're run by the cartels
you understand you report on it all the
time a lot of people do I would be a
terrible thing
Mexico should step up and stop this
onslaught this invasion into our country
John mr. mayor you tried three times to
get a deal on brexit at this point do
you believe that a deal on brexit is
possible or is this a Gordian knot
president Trump says that you didn't
take his advice in terms of negotiation
should you have would that have made a
difference in President Trump if I could
ask to follow up you had a conversation
with Boris Johnson could we ask what you
spoke about and will you meet with
Michael Gove today well first of all on
the first issues I said in answer to an
earlier question I still believe I
personally believe that it is in the
best interest of the UK to leave the
European Union with a deal I believe
there is a good deal on the on the table
obviously it will be for whoever
succeeds me as Prime Minister to take
this issue forward
what is paramount I believe is
delivering on brexit for the for the
British people and I seem to remember
the the president suggested that I sued
the European Union which we didn't do we
went into negotiations and we came out
with a good deal that's not a sued but
that's okay
I would have sued and settled maybe but
you never know she's probably a better
negotiator than I am Jeremy but you know
what she has got it in a sense John that
deal is teed up I think that these
really teed up I think they have to do
something and perhaps you won't be given
the credit that you deserve if they do
something but I think you deserve a lot
of credit I really do I think you
deserve a lot of credit ok yes John so I
know Boris I like him I've liked him for
a long time he's I think he'd do a very
good job
I know Jeremy I think he'd do a very
good job I don't know Michael but would
he do a good job Jeremy time
okay good thank you very much everybody
thank you thank you very much